hey so I'm I'm calling Carol I'm one of
three people who are gonna be up here
talking today the other two are actual
matplotlib developers I'm not a MATLAB
developer I wore a PI MC 3 shirts so
that you could tell where my loyalties
are but I've had a lot of fun putting
this together about how to make custom
plots specific to your domain using that
plot lib and I thought this was a useful
thing to share I think this is really
good for anyone who is either in a in a
company and wants like specific plots
before their data science team or if
you're in some sort of academic lab and
your lab wants to have some sort of
consistent theme and and some plots that
they use often or if you're just a
person and you like sharing your plots
and you'd like your plots look
distinctive I think there's a lot you
can take away from this so the slides
are online they're online right now so I
should have left this stuff while I was
telling you about all the wonderful
things you're gonna be learning but you
can run them you can run them along with
me there they're being hosted as a
static website on github and then that
static website is generally my github
repository so that second one is a
clickable link and it assumes you type
in that first URL then you go and you
click on the second link oh and and lots
of things to the matplotlib team and
contributors so I'm I'm like pine see
talks I did not build any of the
matplotlib code for this and so I'm
really happy that it all works and I do
think it's getting a lot friendlier for
people who are building libraries on top
of it so I think that there's a lot of
work going into it make it nicer for
these domain specific libraries great so
so one point that we have going on here
is that your your your planning
functions should understand your domain
and so one of the I think surprising
things about matplotlib is how often it
can do the thing that you want without
you needing to do extra extra work
around the functions that you're using
and what we're going to go through today
is once you need something extra beyond
like
dotplot how do you go and do that and so
how do you make functions that
understand your domain functions that
make it easier to visualize your data
and to work with the data as you as you
encounter it there are examples in the
in the wild of this RV's is a library
that I help maintain and build for
plotting Bayesian Bayesian data
essentially so doing visualizations of
statistical distributions see board and
plot 9 are both are both sort of
favorites they also they have a lot to
do with statistics plot 9 is a beautiful
sort of grammar of graphics
implementation using that pot lib that's
a really fun library to use both pandas
an x-ray have plots built in so they
understand the the data source that
they're looking at working with and then
you have more domain-specific libraries
so you've got your mapping libraries SK
learned this this was in the what's now
session yesterday the plot partial
dependence and then you've got graven
and X vis this is for network data so
these are libraries already out in the
open open source libraries that you can
use for four specific domains and what
we're going to talk about today is there
are so many scientists here coming from
so many different domains you all should
be building libraries and whether or not
you open-source them is is sort of up to
you oh and if you're following these
along you'll have a link to all the
third-party packages this is on the
matplotlib website and they've assured
me that they will respond to your pull
request with great joy if you build a
library and want them to list it on
there so get on there and an advertise
your library so the first thing I want
to to encourage you to do if you are if
you are working on domain-specific
libraries is to use a style sheet this
is the easiest way to look distinctive
and and to use a consistent style across
all of your projects this probably takes
an hour and it's a lot of fun to do
there are a lot that are right built
into matplotlib I'd encourage you I
would encourage you not to use a built
in style sheet make your own it's really
fun
use the built-in ones if you're if
you're doing something that's
reproducible and you don't want to mess
with installing the style sheet
whatever machine that is but but yeah
make your own it's uh it's a blast so
this is the default style you can go
back to the classic matplotlib style
this has got little black outlines
around the points ggplot I actually took
my first statistics data visualization
course with Headley Wickham Oz at Rice
and he was just sort of starting with
ggplot and this was the theme of his
first talk was don't use a default style
make it something that stands out it's
it's funny now because like GG plot
looks like GG flat you know like
everyone's seen this so many times but
it was it was a very different look at
the time so so this is also built into
matplotlib mount so you can you can go
and use use this one 5:38 super
distinctive they're doing a lot of
really cool work this is also ships with
MATLAB so you can you can use this on
your machine right now much bolder lines
much they're sort of thicker lines very
vibrant colors this is the one that I
make for myself that I use personally
this won't work if you try to use this
on your machine you would need to go and
install my style sheet I base it on some
of the books that Edward Tufte wrote so
the background color is that subtle
beige that he loves if anyone has his
books has anyone read 250 awesome yeah
so so you know what I'm talking about
and I also stole from the beautiful
Altair library they have these these
hollow points as their default markers
and so I stole that cuz I just think
that looks really cool and then the
serif font I'm not sure whether that's
good for reading or bad for reading I do
statistics in that style so there you go
so how do we how do we build these I'm
gonna show you just an interactive way
of going and messing around with the
styles and coming up with a style that
you like for yourself and what we're
gonna imagine here is that we're going
to build a style that we're gonna use
for giving talks at a PI data conference
alright so so we we like giving talks
we're gonna need some plots the plots
often take up the bottom half of our
slide because we have the code on the
top half this is gonna be our just test
function I'll usually write up some
quick test function that looks like the
plots that I like to make and so here's
here's one it doesn't really matter
except that it fits on one line and the
plot doesn't really look like
now it's a little bit small and so I'm
gonna go and use PLT dot RC params not
update so RC params is a dictionary type
object so I can call that update on it
it'll update all the values and then
when I call plot again the default
figure size will be bigger oh oh and we
switch the code on these two so here's
how you update the figure size and on
the previous one I went and updated the
the colors so I updated the three colors
to be the three primary colors for pi
data so that's the orange the blue and
the gray and so now we've got it'll just
keep cycling through those colors so
there are 25 lines here it'll cycle
through the colors eight times and one
third of one more time
and now we've got looking a little more
like pi data there's still some problems
though I don't love the lines I want
some markers on here PI data likes to
use don't even have a welp I did it
likes to use diamonds for their logo
they got sort of four four diamonds on
their logo and so I'm gonna start using
a default marker and I'm gonna set that
equal to D which is which is the
matplotlib for a diamond the lines now
look even more weird so let's get rid of
the lines we can set the line style to
be just empty now when you make it plot
again I'm still just calling PLT dot
plot on that there's 50 random numbers I
will just get a bunch of diamonds on the
screen but now it's a little small so we
should make those bigger so I made a
extra big here's the first time I'm
actually cheating
so I'm sitting clip-on to be false so
now I did have to update my plotting
code the clip on let's your markers go
off the edge of your plot and so that's
that's all that's doing but the edge of
my plots ugly anyways I'm not worried
about where these are where these are
going like no one's really reading the
axis so we're gonna get rid of the
spines the spines are that are the black
box that bounds your plot and so I can
set each of those the top bottom left
and right to off you can imagine only
turning one or two of these two off you
know maybe you want the left in the and
the bottom to be to be activated I also
turn off the ticks on the bottom and the
left you could do something wacky if you
wanted you can turn ticks on on the top
if you wanted to a really special plot
and chicks on on the right or you
haven't on both sides and so now this is
looking much better
I'm gonna do one last artistic flair
here so I'm gonna outline it in black
this is just to make it look really nice
I think this pops now and I think this
is a good default theme of her for
making pie data plots and and so let's
uh so so if we go and play with this
this is a default right so I can go and
override these again when I'm calling
that plot and if I don't I might end up
with some weird-looking plots and if I'm
trying to make art I might have done a
really good job but if I'm trying to
like teach trigonometry and I'm plotting
like sine and cosine like this and maybe
I've done a pretty bad job so so you
should be aware of your domain your
style sheet to respect your domain your
style sheet should do the things that
you most often want to do for you so
make your defaults work for you so what
happens once we had these RC params one
thing I did constantly while I was
working on this stylesheet work on my
own stylesheet is I was printing out the
whole RC params dictionary so I could
see what keys I have access to so this
is how I see like fig fig size and I say
oh if I adjust that I'm gonna be able to
change the default figure size after you
do that you have to convert your output
to this RC params format so the RC
params is going to be a file that you're
gonna put in a certain directory and
it's gonna look in this in this certain
format easiest way to see this is to
just look at an existing RC params file
this one's a valid RC params file and
we're gonna save it as my style NPL
style so we've got a file my style dat
MPL style we're gonna go put it in the
matplotlib configuration directory you
can find out where that is matplotlib
get config dear and then it's an inside
style Lib there and so you can go in
there you can also see what-what Styles
already exists there are ways to do that
from inside the library too but you can
go in there and see other examples of
your style sheets once it's in there
though you can just use your default
Styles so then you don't have to do all
this update params every time you start
a notebook you just open the notebook
call PLT dot style dot use you know name
of your lab and then you'll have this
custom style applied by default whenever
you're plotting so this is this is a
really quick way of getting started on
having just a default look you know
share this file with everyone
lab than any plots that come out from
from your group will all look consistent
they'll look great everyone will be
impressed
you can also pip install this if you're
if you're careful oh and the last thing
I want to say I don't know if anyone
else
whenever you plot with a histogram like
you understand that you should look at
it with 10 bins or 20 bins and there
might be some something weird going on
but I just wanted to do Auto bins first
so that is a choice that you can set you
can set as these defaults using your
stylesheet and so if you go in there and
set his stuff bins to be Auto then you
no longer have to pass that command and
when you're calling PLT dot hist let me
pass off just my last thing he only
meant his section we promised as more
okay now so you have pretty right you
now have a straight corporate look
straight look everything coming out of
your lab we're set how many of you have
a plot y'all need to make all the time
it's like it's the same plot you just
have like you know we need to tweak one
little thing and that's always different
how many of you all have that shoved in
some function in some strange way that's
ends up being not useful except outside
of your one Jupiter notebook haven't you
even put it in a1 Jupiter nope in a
function and don't just copy and paste
the same cell okay so let's talk about
the father or the methyl it recommended
way to package your plotting function so
that we can nicely reuse it dump it into
that PI file share it about step one
wrap your plots what we're doing here is
we're going to make a plotting function
let's make confetti first things first
what okay how many of you you see born
good people so haven't you used to use
on Seabourn you want just do SNS thought
plot and it makes the thing how many of
you would like it so that your own
function if I do my my library dot plot
it'll just make the thing great so that
is why we have that if ax is none ax
equals part at CCA with that will do is
it'll make the
access for you and in matplotlib land
the axis is the thing we plot on so do
that positive you CA now you can just
it's created and the reason we put that
in an if statement like this is how many
of you can get away with just having one
figure one plot on your figuring that's
done how many of you need stuff
side-by-side you need two side by side
three side by side a fifteen panel yeah
so when you need the fifteen panel you
need that option of being able to pass
in the axis so that's why we have as
part of our style guide you pass in the
axis the reason we have that pass in the
axis after the star is Q we only have
one parameter how many of you need to
have more than one parameter that you're
plotting a lot of you right and what we
don't want to happen is we accidentally
pass in the axis as the Y or the K or
the you know Z so if we have that ax
equals none after the star this is a
Python three thing now it's a mandatory
name the argument you have to say ax
equals ax fit to work and the reason now
we don't just shove it into key word
gods is we want to make it explicit that
our key workouts are pastors and with
Matt mark Lib the key workouts are our
shiny customization cuz wait we've done
a stylesheet right how many of you like
I have a set style but now you need to
do something different for this one
thing right this is fairly common so
with the passing through the queue
ACOG's lets you do is overwrite your
style sheet so here we're doing it for
our plot so this will make our confetti
now there's one thing though right which
key we're gonna cure have I set in my
function in my qualta pot the key will
cogs are the things of X is equal to Y
clip-on equals false right and that is
not anything you should do because I've
been told that it creates some kind of
weird vase condition where you're
sometimes compiler does not know what
you're trying to do so base conditions
bad right so what we'll do is on our
second function is we'll use set default
keyword set E
default and we'll do is if your user
passes in clip-on it'll use what your
user pass through if they haven't we've
said false and now because it's always
said one or the other we don't have any
ambiguity of what we're trying to do
because we're just updating the
dictionary here essentially okay
God's also got confetti now what's the
next thing we want to do we've made the
functions we need to use them so let's
use when I use confetti and we just call
it the way we with any other plotting
function in this case we don't even need
a plot dot because it's in a scope right
the thing is sometimes we need to do
more than one plot but when you're
lining we do multiple lines well it's a
planning method of apps access we can
layer two confetti and the second
confetti and because we can pass the
keyword GOG through we can do we can
pass and we can customize we can change
our marker we can change our Marco sighs
because
yes we've set everything in the style
sheet but the style sheet is the first
level you can then like force things out
and update them with your custom
parameters which is what we're doing
here with the marker size and marker
size and the marker and right so you
want to customize and then we also want
to compose so we can pass in our access
we can set up our subplots now we are
gonna have to call two rows of data and
we can layer the line plot at the top
and point thoughts underneath and
because we've set up these functions
with the access right this is how pandas
works this is how Seabourn works it's a
standard pattern if you want to compose
third-party packages you can just layer
that you can pass in your access and
then it puts it on the grid and the
other thing it does which we haven't
shown here is I can now use my plot and
that's in one grid cell and a panda spot
in a second grid cell and a sieve one
part of the third grid cell and a car
dope in a third and I can use all the
libraries together okay great so now we
can make our own plot what happens if
one of Mapple lives something like
if the plot types isn't good enough
right my domain it's just like it just
doesn't exist in the basic set well
Colin will tell you about that
awesome yeah so that the theme here is
we're going sort of deeper and deeper
for more and more customized plots and
so you can get really far just wrapping
the accessors that you have on the
surface here but if your domain need is
is something deeper I'm really
interested in two things my dog and
messing with photographs so we're gonna
wrap a function that does both those
things on the left you can see my dog
his name is Pete he's adorable on the
right where is what we're gonna try to
do we're gonna try to build this today a
bunch of horizontal lines that sort of
approximate what Pete looks like and so
we're gonna need some way of drawing a
line with varying widths and that's if
anyone's ever tried to do that Matt plot
live it's it's a little bit tough so
we're gonna we're gonna have to go dig
in there and build our custom plot so
let me first just describe how we're
gonna build this idea so this isn't as
important about matplotlib it is
important that everyone see how cute his
face is his nice posies is a really cute
dog when you load this into intimate
plot lab you get three matrices right
one for each color channel that's going
to turn out to be more complicated than
we need for dealing with so I'm gonna
immediately cut it down to grayscale and
that's what we're gonna work with for
the rest of this once we have greyscale
I want to figure out some way of turning
this into a bunch of horizontal lines
and one sort of naive way is we could
rate the grayscale as a matrix just a
single matrix it's 600 by 800 all the
valleys are between 0 & 1 I might make
another matrix we'll call it a mask and
it's just 25 lines where the value is
entirely 1 and in between everything
else is zero so we've got we've got this
masked matrix we've got this matrix with
a picture of Pete we can do point wise
multiplication but you can't really see
that there's a dog there necessarily
you're not really discovering anything
else that's not exactly on one of those
25 lines you can only see what's
what's right they're not what's kind of
nearby and I want some way you know this
is a hazy approach I want some way of
seeing like how wide my line should be
at any given point
so it turns out the right idea is
blurring that mask a little bit so I
take the same 25 lines I apply I apply
this sort of vertical blur to it when I
do the same point wise multiplication I
get this nice picture you can you can
see that there's a dog back there
I can pick pick and intensity so at any
pixel darker than that I'm gonna turn it
entirely black and he picks a lighter
than that I'll turn entirely white and
we'll get will get this which is looking
a lot closer to what I'm hoping my end
product will look like from here I go
through I cut it up into the twenty five
bins surrounding each of these each of
these dark lines and I use this
efficient numpy function where I'm just
gonna go walk along each line and count
how wide the dark pixels are around
there and that's gonna be my line width
I went through and tried right because
there you can count upwards and
downwards and I went through and tried
min or mean or median but it turns out
that the the max at the one that looks
right and so once I get that this is the
only point where I need a special
matplotlib function because I want to go
and turn this into lines and so going
from that that last plot to this plot is
the one spot where I needed to need to
build my own custom function this is
still a little thin but what I got to do
was I took the widths that I calculated
using numpy and I passed them in to
matplotlib and got 25 just horizontal
lines with varying widths so I can I can
vary the width along the along the
length of the line this is too thin but
since I have access to the widths and
there's just numpy rays I can just
multiply them by 10 now I've got thicker
lines and they're sort of sketching out
what the dog looks like a little better
again they're just numpy vectors so I
can smooth these out a little bit so you
can see it goes from boxy and then I
just do smooth so this is running a
smoothing kernel along each width vector
and then also since I'm just doing lines
I can also apply any sort of other sort
of styles I want using matplotlib you
can see that where we're going sort of
crazy with doing this but I'll just put
black color on each of the lines and so
it starts goes through this rainbow
color map depending on which which
horizontal line it is
any questions about how we built this
I'm gonna go back and talk about how the
artists how we actually got into the
artist but any time with your dogs on
there yeah yeah so the question was how
how can you see the spaces in the line
when it was just the graph you could you
couldn't see the spaces and so so it was
sort of trying to erase so in this white
space but a lot of it also comes from
this discritization that where I
actually been it up into 25 different
sort of horizontal bins yes this this is
all I'm working with an image right here
and so so this is one object that
matplotlib knows how to plot and then I
turn into another object that it knows
how to plot cool so how does the line
collection actually work I went through
and you know I looked for the right
artists I need to use in order to in
order to work work with this plot that I
want to make I found lying collection
that sounded likely right I need
something that can go and and change the
widths of the line bits midstream and so
you open it up and the first argument it
expects is a segment segment argument
and this is a very nested list so it's a
list of lists of tuples so I decided to
just try this manually first and and so
I enter three different different
segments the first one is just a
constant line all at height 1 the second
one is the line y equals x plus 1 and
then the last one is y equals x squared
I just enter the first 4 integer points
for those I'm just to see what it does a
couple things to notice about the artist
is that I have to actually add it to my
axis so I use ax dot add collection to
add the line collection and on to my
artists on to my axis and then the
second thing is I'm handling the limits
of the plot myself so I'm setting
excellent and Wilin manually but I'm
remembering what my goal is here my goal
is to have a line with where I can
change the width sort of midstream and
so I go and look at the other attributes
that you can pass in colors and line
widths and line styles but it looks like
that applies to each separate line each
of the three lines and not to one single
line so that I'm still not quite there
in terms of changing the width of a
single line but can anyone see with the
with the tools I have available what you
might do from here in order to change a
midstream so I'm gonna I'm gonna
actually what I'm gonna actually go and
each of my segments will just be a line
of length one and the endpoint of the
previous segment will be the start point
of the next segment and this is what I'm
gonna do in order to be able to change
the attributes of a line sort of point
by point
so each segment is gonna be styled
separately so I'm gonna have sort of
sort of these these four points which
defines three line segments and then I'm
gonna be able to pass three colors three
line widths or three whatever styles to
it that I want so this is great
this plots not as flashy or as cool as
the other plots we've been showing so
let's go and make it flashy and cool
because you know that's what we're all
here for how are we gonna do that
I like parabolas prowlers are easy to
work with because they've got curves to
them and you can sort of tell visually
whether you're getting it right so I'm
gonna define X to be my linspace y is
gonna be x squared and then what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna have V stack those
two together so I'm gonna get an N by 2
matrix I bet that there's people with 30
different ways of making an N by 2
matrix out of two vectors and I bet this
is one of the worst ways but this has a
bit of a bank shot to get your your your
nice matrix and then what I do is I pit
together with itself so I take that
entire n by 2 matrix all the way up to
the second to last entry together with
that n by 2 matrix starting at the
second entry going all the way to the
end and that's this is going to do
exactly what I was describing before
where I do the first point goes to the
second point then that second point is
the start of the the next segment it
goes to the next point it keeps on going
down like this and so it's just gonna be
I guess linspace is 100 by default it'll
be a hundred segments all one after
another and I can style them separately
so what does this look like the first
thing we should do is just go test this
actually works so this is the the whole
code to make that work so again I make
the line collection using those segments
I just put together I add the collection
onto my axis I set
X&Y limits and it looks good it looks
like a normal normal parabola so so so
far mission accomplished
not that flashy so let's see what else
we can do our whole goal was to adjust
widths and so I can actually take take
my x-values and set the line widths
based on that so I'm using this trig
function right I'm using the absolute
value because your wits should probably
be positive I didn't even test it if it
did fine if it was negative maybe it
would and then I multiply by 30 so it's
wide enough that it looks reasonable and
now it's getting a little little flash
here but we can do better so the next
thing I do I grab the various color map
and I also apply a a per point color to
my linspace and so this is going to go
and not only do I get the the widths but
I also get the colors and the color has
half the period that the widths do so
you get this sort of cool rotating
effect cool we'll get questions at the
end again you know and I drove this
forward that you should really be
wrapping the custom use cases you want
for your domain into functions so I'm
gonna wrap this into a function this is
essentially encapsulating the little
trick that we did earlier so we're again
zipping the function with itself the the
XY data with itself we're pretty good at
points and then where we're getting the
line collection and I left out some part
where I'm calculating some some
reasonable defaults for your axes once
we have that this took about five slides
earlier to put up and now it only takes
one slide right we can get go right from
the linspace and and nothing in our
nothing in our environment to having a
full plot of a parabola with this wild
coloring and and a great side effect of
this and this is sort of again why I
think everyone should have their own
plotting library for their own specific
domain for their expertise is you can
start playing with this so if it's easy
to plot if it's easy to visualize you're
going to make a lot more interesting
visualizations or going to explore your
space a lot better so so this is sort of
what I did as soon as I got this
function as sort of thinking whether I
could make a movie
and by just faking my eyes into thinking
that I was in three dimensions so this
is still using a two-dimensional
matplotlib plot but I give it three
turns by adjusting the width to go to
zero three times and then I chose the
color map just right so that it kind of
looks as though if you if you squint at
it there's only one side on this thing
so this is a fun plot to make as well
great and limps let's finish up with
with Tom himself hi so the that's a
tough act to follow
so I use this the the last part of this
is once you have a collection of Python
functions you can now package this like
any other Python library with all the
ease and difficulty and contain yeah
that goes with that so I'm gonna shift
gears a little bit from the apply to
practical to a bit more philosophical
might be a little strong but like how
how I think about matplotlib and that
there's this tent there so map all the
really has two very distinct phases one
of which is it with just an application
so Kielty dot plot like it makes it get
if you just have an x and a y it gets
them on the screen as quickly as
possible
PLT does scatter yeah you can get your X
Y and your Sun your bubble size up in
one line of code but on the other hand
it also serves as a library you know as
a base library for building these more
involved visualizations and then this
then this duality leads to a particular
sets of tensions right because if you
want a library think it's the goal of a
library is not necessarily to be used at
a repla by the end user it's to help
someone build tools for that end user
where as an application is to help you
you know help the unused or do something
right now as quickly as possible on one
hand if you're a library you want to be
very explicit you want to have lots of
arguments you want them to have nice
long readable names if something goes
wrong you want to raise you know you
want to fail fast
and let whoever is calling you sort out
what to do because you know the handling
yeah the reason we have exception is
because you don't know what to do
I was on the other hand an application
is supposed to do the right thing but
experiment you know in my experience if
you ask five scientists what the right
thing to do in a pressure situation is
you'll get about six answers it's like
the right thing is a very subjective
thing that can be very specific to to
domain to what that particular site you
know to the degree of like what that
particular person is doing and that you
know when there when things fail you
know or what the default should be one
personal argue very strong it should be
a and the other person will argue very
strong will be be and that within their
spaces they're both completely right but
at the core library level we can't do
both a and B we have to do something so
I think the the message I would like to
take away from this is that if
matplotlib is not serving you like out
of the box correctly as an application
please build the interface you need on
top of us
so the to wrap up the you know the the
the lowest investment is just wrap the
base function so if you don't like the
default behaviors quite right if you
want to if you want to tweak something
about the signatures you can write a
short little five line function that
turns it from our you know very general
one to one that's very tuned to whatever
you do day to day as you type this will
be more involved one is to do a column
showed us at the end of writing a
function that doesn't use any of our
built-in plotting routines but as you
instantiate s' the artists directly to
you know with what you know based on
whatever input you need to give it and
the third which we're not you know we're
not going to touch on today that's
actually possible to write your own
artists if you need to do something
that's completely out of out of what we
we ship in the base library but as long
as you provide the correct right
interface you can drop that into an
actus and I'll draw draw like anything
else so with that please if you have any
questions if you're working out through
probably library please come talk to us
I've really stood up a discussion
her I would love to hear from all of you
and so with that are there any questions
a new figure or they get the current
access so the question was we you know
in the end and here we're doing guilty
that GCA to get the current access which
if no actions exist will create one and
if you have one it will use it um I
think that's that is an
application-specific question there's
some context where you want your plot
function to be able to add it overlay
onto an existing figure and there's
others or you might be you know your
function might be setting up a multi
panel figure in that case there's not
clear how it should figure out what axes
on that figure are there and it should
make a new figure and if like if you
look at pandas dataframe dot plot does
peel Teta subplots inside to get you a
new figure and series dot plot does peel
to that GCA to add it to whatever axis
you're working on and so that's a that's
something that you can tune based on
what your needs are so the question was
if you're setting our C frames that's a
global parameter animals that will
affect every plot made so you can use we
have context managers for our c4 amps so
you can do with you know I think it's
it's with style passing a dictionary of
RC params and those will be applied
within that context block and
when you come out they get reset to the
default port or whatever the current
status also you can do the width style
with just the name of your style so like
with style 538 which is also if you're
doing like a giant notebook and you want
to mess around with different styles you
can do all of that within context so you
don't screw up your whole plot Lisp is
your style guide available online
somewhere in non-video form so you're
saying things like you should accept a
argument named ax and if it's none set
it to PLT GCA
like the other guidelines like that okay
they're gonna look for it in the docs
it's in our talks and the developers
draw either on the oh it's on the
tutorials usage it's a section called
like how do we the prefer wrapping guide
questions
also we forgot to mention it but as part
of this whole build maintainable
libraries we also have our own test
suite called MPL tests so when you build
your library you can then test your
library you can write functions against
it you can do pure image test which is a
lot how we do a lot of our testing so as
part of the packaging stuff and again if
you want to learn more about that reach
out to us
discourse Twitter find us here all the
things Oh spin tomorrow right we're
gonna be sprinting tomorrow nine to
twelve all right please thank you our
speakers
[Applause]